I look like um bamm-bamm is that the
girl yeah hurt
yeah it's bamm-bamm and bean bump hi
everyone my name is Tamara chambers this
is my talented badass hilarious friend
Sally who is joining me for the scary
portion of our Christmassy theme to
December
Tamara's never seen we put up a poll on
Twitter asking if we should watch black
Christmas or Silent Night deadly night
and Silent Night deadly night one so
hurry we're gonna watch that everyone
doesn't have it so we're like alright
we'll watch the original black Christmas
so today we're going to watch the new
black Christmas remake I'm pretty
excited I'm not I don't I I saw Silent
Hill and it rocked my world and ever
since been a very very scar okay but
what if it was Silent Hill with Santa or
like silent silent night Silent Night
deadly night that's what we're SPO
alright let's go
[Music]
go go go go so we just watched the
remake of black curse
I wasn't even scared I was just
disappointed we called of every single
wave every death every murder weapon it
was so bad and surprisingly so because
the cast going into it seemed really
good I liked a lot of great women yeah
have been in a lot of not only horror
films but just other bigger budget film
and TV shows yeah question
we weiners none for you Gretchen
generally speaking remakes are worse
than the originals because the originals
good and it made money and it's like wow
people want to see this again so they
just remake it cuz they're out of ideas
generally speaking not in every case but
generally speaking it's worse than the
yes and in this case I imagine it is
definitely the case I think in a sense
you could say that it was fun if you
were going into it knowing it was bad
I'd usually like really bad for
ourselves like that's so bad it wasn't
the good kind of bad the writing made no
sense like all of a sudden leave just
shows up this sister just shows up out
of nowhere in the blizzard when no one
can leave the house because all the fake
snow is falling too hard on them that
was an LA winter y'all it's a fake a
snow Silent Night deadly night has like
a like a mall Santa going around killing
people like this this just had Christmas
kind of just shoving like I didn't feel
like a Christmas no they just had
continuous jingle bells I play about one
and a half pages of notes which usually
I write like seven or eight pages what a
Jim the movie opens and you see the bad
guy who's just from The Simpsons for the
straight-up
Burt Burt is in a cell they give
everyone in the in the insane asylum the
kid came for Christmas and Sally's like
well that's gonna be made into a shoe
two seconds later oh the security
guard I think over everyone else
was be worse act like we were remember
him and he was in the first three
minutes yeah but he's still count to
maybe five lines yeah my next note is
because I saw the the girls who are cast
who are like people I recognize so like
the cast is amazing and then two seconds
later when I saw the yes like the cast
is terrible
the sorority sister who's wearing a
button-up shirt a giant-ass shawl but
she's watching porn so she dies cuz in
horror films there's that trope that
like the dies she was in a
button-up and it all and but just cuz
she's watching porn it done done so so
they're in the sorority house and all
these sorority sisters are like giving
their really quick back stories super
fast cuz there's like eight of them and
you find out that they're like we're
celebrating Christmas and every year we
give Billy a present and Billy is the
Simpsons ass character and they're like
because he used to live here this is
where all these men we like honor him so
we won't murder our sisters time around
I don't know what sorority Kappa Billy
didn't break in
Billy lived here the story of Billy is
that like he lived with his mom and and
his stepdad Billy's mom yeah had sex
with Billy Billy which is a very
horrific mom and made a child's Agnes
Agnes who is Billy's daughter slash
sister the mom and stepfather locked
Billy up in the attic and Billy escaped
one Christmas took adness was like she's
my family now and then killed the mom
and stepfather ate the mom and then has
been meeting ristmas cookies out of her
skin
it was a bit much so we who we thought
was Billy but was actually a gist
surprised shocked spoilers Agnes is
going around killing the sorority
sisters and taking the girls phones who
she kills and then yelling them from the
phone and being like she's nice family
now and then one of the sorority sisters
had a call from Megan and it was like
she's my family now and he's like well
that's just not Megan yeah we know a
girl the boyfriend of one of the
sorority sisters it's like well I can't
be here after after dark because it's
the story to use so I snuck into one of
the other sisters rooms crawled through
so I could have sex with you and then
later they were in her room the girl
that he snuck through the room up and
his girlfriend was like we don't know
where she is maybe maybe we'll check her
computer and he was like I don't feel
like I wanna like breach her security
like that hope to ride the seat you
crawled through her window you just you
Robin boom you douche and also how did
you know that that was her room they
check her computer to see if she has any
emails midnight locate where she is
somehow because I always email people my
address and my whereabout where I am and
all space aliens which can be a jewel so
they look at our computer remember that
porn that shawl lady was watching but
nut shell girl it was him banging her
baby she's all lady and the boyfriend
that was the only thing that got us we
body lies
worst superhero duo ever yeah shall lady
and juicy boyfriend
I just wrote here so many problems not
even a specific note just so many people
I mean you're not wrong there's one
point where one of the sorority sisters
is so drunk she's like throwing up and
taking a shower and some of the tiles
from the bamboo floor papa and you just
see a crazy eye from the bottom has a
yellow skin around it he's just like
whoa the ground is here she's up here
and he's underground there's no more
light in here at 6:00 he could but he
couldn't see her that is a perfectly
arched back with her ass sticking out
girl I mean she looked fine that leg but
you couldn't see now his Simpson hi it's
done see so Agnes and Billy's at
you like villains of the movie are in
body bags cuz they're supposedly dead
and then they burst out of the body bags
both of them and somehow survived and
looked dead enough to get into a body
bag like place low enough at least it's
not any pull they spring Alex spring
chickens and they're like killing people
in the hospital then they get to the
blogs girl who then kills Stumbo
we talk about oh my god
so Agnes that's a woman Billy's younger
sister who's also his daughter who is
played by a man in this movie almost
there something I'm missing it just it
didn't make any snow would you watch the
original I want to watch the original
just because the Twitterverse was like
it's actually legitimate like watch it
don't watch the remake yeah this movie I
wasn't scared of no it wasn't scary no
no no it just wasn't good it wasn't
well-written it
despite the actors being like promising
whatever yeah I like a lot of deserters
I would blame it on the script I think
it's what I want to do in my heart well
this is the last one for December next
week I will be back with an on themes
Tamra's never seen let me know in the
comments what you would like to see what
I still haven't done I'd have a couple
I've got like Karate Kid and Lethal
Weapon and I've never seen whoa see it's
not just Tamra check out our power hours
on my personal channel thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
you